[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing jk rowling the harry potter
books
and the mysterious group that preceded
the death eaters
now we know the death eaters as the
loyal servants and followers of the dark
lord
lord voldemort becoming a death eater
means that you bear the dark mark
a symbol that is representative of their
group the group even uses the dark mark
as a way of inciting fear in the general
population
projecting it into the sky using the
curse
mor mord arthur weasley expresses his
fear of this symbol in the goblet of
fire
you know who and his followers sent the
dark mark into the air whenever they
killed
the terror it inspired you have no idea
you're too young
just picture coming home and finding the
dark mark hovering over your house
and knowing what you're about to find
inside everyone's worst fear
the very worst in essence the death
eaters were a group of pure blood
radical supremacists
intent on cleansing the world of
muggle-borns and half-bloods
in the pursuit of a purer wizarding
community but
one thing that is worth mentioning is
the death eaters that we come to know in
the books and films
were not always operating in a way that
we are familiar in an old interview with
news round from 2003
rolling reveals a snippet of information
about a group that
preceded the death eaters and these
scraps of paper which you've filed
elegantly in a carrier bag
their plot ideas or well some of them
are totally redundant now because
it's been written um and i keep it out
of sentimental
sentimentality's sake i suppose but some
of it um
uh that has backstory in like this this
is um
in here is uh the history of the death
eaters
and i don't know that i'll ever actually
it's in the front so i'll ever actually
need it
but at some point which were once called
something different they were called the
knights of walpurgis
um well i don't know if i'll need it but
i like knowing
so you know i like to keep that sort of
stuff on hand so
the knights of walpurgis what's all that
about
who were they when tom riddle was just a
boy he attended hogwarts
just like everyone else and he was
sorted into slytherin house
riddle's cunning and manipulative nature
eventually meant that he would form a
gang of sorts a group consisting of his
fellows that they're in students
the gang that riddle formed was once
described by dumbledore as a
mixture of the weak seeking protection
the ambitious seeking glory
and the thuggish seeking a leader who
could show the more refined cruelty
and interestingly enough it was the
members of this gang that were
considered to be the forerunners to what
we know now
as the death eaters with that in mind i
think that we can fairly safely put a
label on riddle's gang
how about oh i don't know the knights of
all purges
so the knights of walpurgis were fellow
sitheran students that were classmates
of tom riddle
sure but how did they come up with a
name like that
what is the significance of such a name
i was intrigued
so i did a bit of digging from what i've
been able to find
the closest thing relating to walpurgis
that makes sense
is valparkisnat or walpurgis night
which is a pagan holiday that falls on
the eve of the feast of saint walpurgis
a saint of the roman catholic church put
quite simply
will perk his night was when according
to the belief of millions of people
the devil was abroad when the graves
were opened and the dead came forth and
walked
and all evil things of earth and air and
water held revel
additionally albergue's night has always
been associated with witchcraft
and witches for that matter in german
folklore for example
on wall burgers night which is from all
over the land would gather
for a great sabbath on top of the broken
also known as the bloxberg
the highest peak of the hearts mountain
range expanding on the fact that
wolperka's night was a night when
witches and other evil entities were
roaming freely around the land
it should also be worth noting that
certain practices were developed to keep
them at bay
for example on wall burgers night in
germany people would dress up in
costumes
and make loud noises i found the whole
history of walpurgis night very
interesting
and just from looking into it very
briefly i can really understand where
rowling was coming from
with regards to the name of riddle's
gang the close associations with witches
witchcraft the devil and the dead seem
fitting for a group that would
eventually go on to become
death eaters i also found it interesting
that german people would dress up in
costumes
to keep the evil entities at bay as i
think this may perhaps loosely allude
to the attire that we end up seeing the
death eaters wearing
what do you guys think is there anything
else that we know about the knights of
war pergas
that i've missed did you know about the
history of walpurgis already
let us know down in the comment section
below until next time
you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you